okay welcome everyone
and
sorry for the short delay just getting
over a couple of small technical
difficulties but Welcome to our event
the
peer master class on how to start your
project management career in six months
with the University of Massachusetts
Amherst the Eisenberg School of
Management my name is Stuart Creek I am
a marketing manager here at simply learn
and with me today is Brian Campbell one
of our expert instructors in fact a
little bit about Brian why don't you um
tell your story Brian because you do it
better than I
uh you're on mute I'm sorry we it
happens when we trans transition to life
oh gotcha yeah thanks for calling that
out so uh hello everyone it's great to
spend a little time with you
um so yes I am a a project program
manager
um these acronyms you see in front of
you stand for things like the project
management professional the program
management professional and the project
management institute's agile certified
professional all these are
certifications offered by the project
management Institute which is sort of
the leading
um
project
um
bought a authorization certification
body so I do a lot of work with PMI as
well as a lot of work in traditional and
more agile related practices
and I've been doing this for a long time
I think those two and I currently late
to the fact that you know we start
getting a lot more gray here uh
appearing and that's just a sign of all
the the time we've spent working in
different organizations so most of my
background has been exclusively project
and program management experience
oftentimes helping organizations with
things at large-scale Transformations we
want to shift from traditional project
management to maybe to Agile so I do a
lot of work in that space I contribute a
lot to some of the literature out in the
industry like the project management
body of knowledge or pin block and I do
a lot of work with organizations like
simply learn creating course content to
help people that want to learn more
about project management and get their
certifications
very good
so let me
um speak a little bit about our agenda
today we'll be talking about project
management careers and then we'll go
into how you can prepare for a career in
project management with the program from
the University of Massachusetts Amherst
we'll talk about how the program gets
you job ready Brian will be able to show
us the Learning System that supports it
and will take some of your questions at
the end so you can put those into the Q
a box or WebEx
and
about careers in project management
project management is a universal skill
in business
the universal skill in life really
because
in any endeavored we plan out what we
want to do and we execute that plan and
that's project management whether you're
deciding to buy a home or a car or fix
something
um
you need to plan out the steps you're
going to take
what schedules are going to occur in and
then execute them and make sure that
they're executed properly so in business
sometimes the stakes are higher but it's
a similar type of process and it's
evolved over the years we
traditionally thought of
project management in terms of discrete
steps that's that's very different today
isn't it brand
it definitely in fact
one of the things we've we've recognized
and seen in the industry in the market
is that it's a pace of change is just so
fast so high so some of those those old
style uh practices that you know we we
leveraged in the past very prescriptive
linear uh processes now we're having to
develop some very modern project
management techniques where we're taking
advantage of all these digital tools
that are starting to emerge things like
Ai and machine learning which is
actually really helping the project
management space so all these uh skills
are are so important but as you pointed
out they're sort of the universal things
that we're pulling on here and some
things just haven't changed people are
going to ask when is it going to get
done how much is it going to cost and
this is where project management is is
always sort of focused helping
organizations and people understand
those answers to those questions
excellent thank you
um yeah it has applications of course in
every industry every company and it's
really
extremely powerful because it allows you
to
um
control the flow of work within the
company both on the day-to-day level and
for
one-off types of events
company for example simply learned just
acquired a company that was a project in
and of itself so
um
right project management skills
again the
skills of a project manager in the
traditional model
developed the project plan manage the
deliverables that thing type of thing so
uh can can you comment a bit about the
about these skills and how they're
maybe a little bit different in the
modern era of agile and scrum yeah great
great question so yeah you know some of
the things you're seeing here definitely
universally applied to all types of
projects as I mentioned before
um you know you're gonna get asked as a
project manager often saving a teaching
course is the two questions you get
asked are how much is it going to cost
and when will it get done so we do need
to have a plan that helps support that
and we need to manage the deliverables
that people expect and get people to
deliver the work recruit staff all
that's going to be important but when we
think of sort of the domain the
environment that we're operating in
right now I mean it's got to be so
responsive we have to be so adaptive you
know the best laid plans often have to
shift and change we're seeing that all
the time so this is where that concept
you mentioned of agility starts entering
into the mix we want to develop project
plans that are adaptive that are
flexible that are responsive so uh so
we're going to hear a little bit more
about them that's a real Cornerstone of
this whole program it's not just sort of
the one I use the term your your
grandfather's project management
um this is this new very Progressive Way
in which we can manage and deliver our
projects using techniques like agile
thank you so I want to confirm
um right now Brian I'm having a
interesting view of my windows here are
you seeing the uh
the initial title slide of the
presentation are you seeing the poll
question
oh I'm not seeing the poll question did
you pop a pull question up
uh I'm about to
um bear with me for just a moment I need
to um
okay okay
yeah maybe as Stewart's doing that you
know maybe to talk a little bit further
about what does project management look
like in this new domain and this is an
area that you know I've been spending a
lot of time with the project management
Institute on which is that project
managed now increasingly is getting
spread out across so many parts of the
organization a lot of organizations are
realizing hey keeping project management
in just one self-contained part of the
company organization isn't very
impactful we want everyone to have these
skills and we're going to hear a little
bit more about the career opportunities
that project management offers but I
think this is one of the more compelling
ones the need for these kinds of answers
have not gone away organizations are
still always going to need a way in
which they manage work and project
managers are going to be important part
of doing that and we're seeing that this
is extending across every aspect of an
organization now it's not just
centralizing one project management
office so uh so kind of exciting time if
you're interested in pursuing more of a
formal project management career
Direction
and how are we doing Stuart were you
able to wrestle the technical issues
you might still be uh working on that
and I did notice there are a couple
questions
um like you know what what technical
knowledge do good project managers bring
to the table
um now I will tell you this as a
consultant I work for many many
different organizations and a lot of
times I just don't have that domain
knowledge that some people in those
organizations that have been there 20
maybe 30 years have so it's not always
critical for a project manager have that
in-depth technical knowledge
you're going to rely on expertise that
you have on your teams but
great project managers are the ones that
can quickly come up to speed on some of
those technical topics or the business
domains that they're operating in so uh
and that's part of what makes this a
really interesting industry I'm always
shifting into new projects learning
about new areas you know whether it's
oil and gas I'm based in Houston Texas I
do a lot of work in oil and gas but also
Healthcare do a lot of work with
Healthcare clients those are very
different Industries it's so fascinating
learning about how they operate and and
manage so
um so that makes project manager I think
pretty exciting space to be in
okay
I'm still having a little difficulty
with the sharing function so I may have
to um
do a little bit of work here to get that
guideline but
um I do want to share a poll question
with you get that going
so
I had to drop off and restart my
connection here really oh no I was
calling
causing a problem here so hold on for
just a moment
yeah by the way I'm looking the chats
here we got some great project
management center questions here uh
really enjoying what we were putting the
checking your deliverables need to your
commitments things like that so uh great
great job folks uh glad to see so many
people with some some background in this
space
all right
so
let's
sphere this poll question and we are
working
um so if you're seeing the poll question
you should also be seeing it and
uh your
poll widget
and
you have about 10 seconds to answer this
is basically why you haven't engaged in
a comprehensive project management
program like this one up until now
if you're already in the program we
thank you for that um but if not
asking why you haven't done something
like this before
and the answers uh half of the audience
says that you don't feel the program is
going to give you the Practical
experience exposure that you're going to
be able to confidently state to a
potential employer yes these are the
skills I have and this is how I've
demonstrated them so
um and
significant number of people
um talk about not finding the time in
their work schedule and not finding a
comprehensive program so let's address
some of those issues we'll talk about
the
program itself now before we get to that
I want to cover one other
um
thing that we missed
during my difficulties here
you need a suite of skills for project
management those some of the skills
certified as a project manager
understanding agility the agile and
agile scrum environment understanding
how to Min risk
understanding being processes and
principles
tools like Microsoft Project and then
how to implement project management
within your particular organization how
to use it for digital transformation
which is a particular interest today so
we talk about the
graduate program
postgraduate program
in project management
sharing the correct window
yeah we can see it in the other
good enough
um so the postgraduate program in
project management from the University
of Amherst
is a six-month program we'd say it takes
about 10 to 15 hours a week of dedicated
time
second
turn this into
there we go
oops sorry
um
it provides a comprehensive curriculum
it covers all of the types of skills
that Brian and I have spoken about up to
now
um it it does this in a completely
online
format on the learning management system
a platform that allows you to take
online live virtual classes with
instructors like Brian your commitment
is to show up to those classes for eight
hours a week usually four hours Saturday
four hour Sunday and then do the
homework in between the classes are on
the schedule
six times but your homework your project
work can be done anytime 24 7 in between
the classes uh so you can fit it to
whatever your lifestyle whatever your
work schedule allows and
um
be confident that if you happen to be up
at three o'clock in the morning working
on a project you have the ability to
turn to your peers through the community
chat board
then
raise a request with are 24 7 support
staff both about the technical
workings of the platform but also about
the subject matter uh you can reach out
to your instructor and send an email
that they'll get the next morning and
all of those tools allow you to continue
working without getting stuck on a
blocker or a doubt and
the platform allows you to do all of
your project work
in the same environments
do it on your laptop or desktop you can
actually watch a lot of the content on
your mobile device and
gives you a
uniform uh comfortable way to deal with
all of the work you do in the program
and what you end up with is a
certificate issued by UMass Amherst and
by simply learn
verifying that you have completed the
program all the core courses you have
the skills that
those courses cover you have the ability
to take all the
elective courses along the way at no
extra cost dude you've done your
Hands-On case studies and projects
including the all-important Capstone
project which is your final project for
the the course and essentially
um serves as a final exam if you will
along the way you can take master
classes with
UMass Amherst instructors
and you qualify for Alumni Association
membership
we'll also talk about the job assist
services that are available Learners
pardon me in the US
and in India for those of you in other
countries I apologize those are the only
two countries where we do the job assist
Services as part of the course
so
I'm going to mention a little bit about
UMass Amherst but a 130 year old Public
University
ranks consistently in the top U.S
universities and it has one of the older
business schools in the United States in
fact in the world Business Schools came
into spoke after the second world war
and University of Massachusetts Amherst
was one of the first 1847
um this graduate program gives you both
the final certificate and then
certificates along the way uh for
different courses within the program
master classes Alumni Association
membership and if you are inclined to
enroll in the University's online MBA
program
the
um
this program will give you nine credits
that you can transfer into the Eisenberg
online MBA program so that's a separate
program run by the university but this
is a good way to get a head start on
that as well
and people will recognize UMass Amherst
on your on your CV on your resume
um as one of the more prestigious
institutions in the world
we're very proud to work with them and
we're
we have a very simple set of
requirements
prerequisites for this program
um
you
only have to be a bachelor's graduate
you have to have a bachelor's degree in
any discipline or to qualify if you have
a higher degree as well
um
you must have a minimum of five years of
work experience this does not
intended for people coming straight out
of University
it is for people who have some work
experience some real life experience in
the Working World and that's because
this is where the project management
skills that we're training you in will
be applied so I want you to understand
the inner workings of organizations and
how this fits in with them so
you do not however have to have any
programming skills you may or may not
come into this program with programming
skills if you do that's great if you
don't it's not a problem
so let me ask a question related to this
set of prerequisites
and
how much experience do our audience
members have this is again work
experience
not tied particularly with project
management but just in general in the
workplace
let this run
about another 10 seconds
keep glancing over at the results as
they're coming in so
Brian you can see that we have a very
experienced audience today yeah it looks
great
it's impressive for the people in the
first two categories less than two years
uh you'll want to keep this on your
radar for for the future for people in
the two to five year category you're
probably on the verge of being eligible
for the program or will be soon but the
rest of the audience
um with five or more years of experience
that that covers about three quarters of
you so great to see and
at this point I'm going to ask Brian
to share his screen so that he can talk
to you about these aspects of the
learning environment so I'm going to
stop sharing here
okay
transfer
transfer that privilege to you awesome
awesome yeah notice that's great great
to see so many people in attendance and
I've been looking at the questions
people are asking we'll get our we'll do
our best to answer most of these in the
time we have not sure we'll get them all
but uh thanks for for popping those in
there all right let's see if we can uh
do some screen sharing here can you see
my screen
yes I do awesome awesome okay so um
like Stewart said we want to spend a
little time with what I think is is one
of the most compelling reasons to uh to
take advantage of the simply learn
postgraduate program here through the
University of math
Massachusetts Amherst program is the
learning management system itself the
LMS this is state-of-the-art this is
something that simple learn has been uh
you know building and refining over many
years which makes it very easy for
people to navigate find the information
they need and for most of us we are
learning while we are doing other things
you know working raising families
participating in all the activities that
are important to us so
um I find that this this product is is
really valuable just in terms of its
ability to be used anywhere you heard
Stuart say you can you know pull a lot
of these videos up on your mobile device
so if you've got a lunch break or you
just got some time somewhere you can you
can immerse yourself in a lot of the
content so um I've already clicked
through logged in to the Learning
Management platform we can see
um we are at the postgraduate program in
project management and here we have all
the different courses that are available
and you heard Stewart already spend a
little time talking about a number of
them things like our project management
professional the PMP
scrum that's an agile scrum Master
course risk management such an important
part of managing things like schedules
and budgets is understanding our risk
exposure and coming up with plans to
manage our risks on a project
we do need a rich set of skills as a
project manager so things like our
certified lean Six Sigma program where
we're gonna learn about how can we make
our processes efficient how can we track
our processes and ensure that they're
conforming to the standards that we have
digital transformation this is such an
important area right now because so many
organizations are making that shift to
more of a digital way of working and
delivering we're gonna learn about tools
things like Microsoft project
um can it get Hands-On with important
tooling that enables project managers
implementing a pmo a project management
office how do we coordinate all the
projects within an organization and then
this Capstone project we're going to
hear a little bit more about this is an
opportunity to really kind of take all
the skills that we've learned through
the program and apply them in a real
world contemporary
case study that will really showcase all
of your skills and can use as part of
your portfolio so a quick question Brian
right now we're looking at we're looking
at your Microsoft teams window oh my bad
my bad sorry about that let me uh switch
the uh you know what I uh the whole time
thanks for pointing it out yeah all
right let me uh it's actually actually
our attendees who brought that tour oh
thank you for that yeah my bad so uh let
me uh so you've heard a little bit about
it let me uh
I mean sure sorry about that you know
probably having two monitors I guess
sometimes that happens so uh there's
that there's also the the problem of
WebEx but we want to assure our audience
that uh simply learned we'll be doing
these webinars on Zoom within the next
couple of weeks so
um but we are singing we are seeing the
um learning management system now so
thank you
excellent okay so you heard me talk a
bit I kind of ran through the list here
of courses so these are the courses that
I can kind of visualize it a little more
uh in addition to hear me talk about it
so you can see the different courses
we've got
um each one of these are a little tile
very easy to both visually see
understand what they are and dive into
notice a few of these are going to say
self-learning and live classes so some
of this is self-paced learning you can
take the content the videos that have
been recorded you can start uh looking
at that you know whenever it's
convenient and then there's gonna be
live courses taught by people like
myself and other
um Experience Project program managers
so you'll have a chance to kind of also
attend those sessions so a couple
different flavors in which you can
pursue
um we're just about after I'd gone
through the list of all the different
courses here you can see them
um I was just about to click on a few so
you can see them a little more directly
so let's click on our PMP now this one
has an update and that's I think a
really important thing to be aware of
similar is always investing in the
content that they've created making sure
it's up to date
um that it reflects current trends and
directions now I'm not going to update
it right now just to save us the time so
I'm just going to reserve learning but I
think that's really important to call
out
so you can see right off the bat
I'm jumping into a video so we've got a
uh uh on the right hand side sort of our
course content here and you can jump to
any part of the course content we've got
uh videos that are going to come up
these are really engaging you can see
how a professional these look so they've
really invested in creating a positive
learning experience for you all
uh in addition to the self-learning and
the videos you have you've got some
assessments you can take
and you can aligns already expired
um because I'm an instructor so they
just give me this uh when I need it so I
said but in this particular case you
could take an assessment you've got four
assessments you can take and for anyone
that's interested in taking the PMP
certification exam this is incredibly
valuable because it gives you a chance
to practice this is a very demanding
exam so having an opportunity to kind of
practice and get some exposure to the
types of questions and make sure you
really understand all the content is
very very valuable you can see on the
left hand side too if we look at the
screen here we've got our live classes
okay you'll be able to see a list of
when the live classes are you can check
on your certificate once you've
completed all the necessary activities
you will unlock this achievement and
immediately you can add that to your
portfolio is something you've
accomplished so each one of the courses
has this type of structure which makes
it from my perspective really easy to
get to what you need to learn and get
ways in which you can validate your
learning so each one of these programs
has the the same structure you're going
to have different courses is you can
click into we can look at things like
the agile scrum master
and it's the same structuring format so
that consistency is helpful you know you
don't have to relearn things every time
you go into each one of the courses
again the same high quality learning
experience notice there's some tooling
that starts to merge we've got some
self-learning we've got a project this
time a smart weather with jira jira is a
a very prominent industry-leading agile
Work Management tools you can actually
get a chance to see these tools in
action learn about them we've got
reference materials things like case
studies you can take you can download
the course slides if you want to go back
through those so anyways really really
rich experience I do want to bring your
attention to one other thing that I
think is really impactful is this
community button one of the things
simply learned is known for is a great
Community although they're Learners so
you'll be able to engage with your
learning cohort all the other people
involved in the program and structures
like myself are in the forums if you
have a question if there's a topic you
want to dig into you can post it there
instructors and other student
participants will all be able to kind of
chat and talk about this so I find that
really enriches The Learning Experience
Stuart what else what else should I show
I think you you mentioned the community
forums and
um
are there any other
resources like the files that the uh
instructors share with students other
resource sections that people yeah
definitely definitely so yeah you'll see
in each of the courses uh there will be
things like case studies you can click
on this link case studies zip file will
be downloaded you can spend some time uh
digging through each of those
um look like I did mention we've got the
communities at um
simplylearn.com
and you can go to those kind of get a
little bit more Exposure oops did I type
that wrong maybe I did
um
let's see if I can I can get to it from
here but uh all these are are great ways
to just stay connected with the
participants and the structure
instructors uh so really encourage you
to spend some time with that and I might
be struggling a little bit it's on it uh
I can't remember maybe it's just
community.com
oh looks like there's maybe a little uh
connection issue going on right now
um but that's a great place to spend
some time just posting questions and
getting people kind of exposed to
different topics
all right
thank you for that tour and I'm going to
resume our presentation but give me just
a moment to do that
and
taking back
the sharing
okay
all right so we've looked at the live
tour
um and we're going to talk a little bit
now about the curriculum itself so
um you had described that as you went
through the modules but I want to
um just point out that this is a program
that's set up in a
stepwise fashion
way that will
um
develop your skills
step by step so that each course
prepares you to take the next course and
succeed
so can you just describe how that
um
sequence happens Brian in terms of what
the different skills are yeah absolutely
so uh yeah and you're exactly right I
mean one way to think about this is you
know simply learn with the University of
Amherst I've really spent some time
thinking about so so what's the learning
path and let's make sure we create the
right foundation so that people can
build on that and extend and refine
their learning so um we're going to
start with the PMP which is sort of the
the classic uh building block for all
things project management related this
is the project management professional
certification this is where you're going
to get exposed to the project management
body of knowledge or pmbok
um and that's going to give you a great
framework for managing large complex
projects and by the way I think that's
known as the question is this just it
related there's absolutely a bit of a
focus on it delivery initiatives but the
thing that the project management
professional Foundation is it extends to
every industry doesn't matter what
industry you're in you could be in
construction you can be Transportation
you can be in healthcare this Foundation
is something you can use across all
those Industries then we're going to
introduce these agile Concepts agile the
scrum Master how that helps create high
performing teams that can deliver value
around products and projects then we're
going to shift to some tooling we're
going to look at project Microsoft
Project which is the the dominant
project scheduling product in the market
once we've got that expertise under a
belt we shift into how do we Implement a
project management office or a pmo how
do we set that what does that look like
what are the different forms of pmos
that exist and now with all that we are
armed and ready to tackle our project
management Capstone project and I know
we're going to get into that a little
bit more detail Stewart but this is a
great opportunity to showcase all the
skills you've been learning to create
something you can show to your current
employer or prospective employers on how
you can manage projects
yep
um along the the sideline there you see
the electives which are classes that you
can take they are included in the cost
of the program so you don't pay extra
for them they're based on your uh
interest your commitment and your
willingness to take those classes uh
they're all available to you and
certainly the UMass Amherst project
management master classes with UMass
instructors
are extremely valuable but each of these
other
electives gives you a more concentrated
uh
focus on a particular skill or
certification so we do recommend that if
you have the time
that you look into taking
these electives as well so
that
builds up your skill set and then Brian
if you can comment about how people will
be exposed to and use some of these
tools and platforms
yeah so um along the way and you got a
little flavor for it when I showed the
uh the one uh agile scrum Master course
you saw the word jira there
and if you're not familiar with jira
that's a uh again a leading Work
Management tool used by many agile teams
and initiatives so you're going to get
exposed to products like jira
um project Microsoft Project of course
Microsoft Office minitab which is uh
very useful for statistical analysis and
we start looking at our lean Six Sigma
topics we're going to use minitab and
and some of the features it uses to help
us calculate statistical variation and
then on the left hand side we've got
some of these Frameworks you know demand
which again is sort of a lean Six Sigma
process
structure to kind of help us manage all
the complexity comes in lots of our
projects initiatives we've got agile the
PMI pmbok version 6 and 7 which is the
new standard of the project manage the
body of knowledge and of course lean Six
Sigma so think of these as we've got
Frameworks on on the left hand side
which are going to tell us or you know
give us guidance on how to manage
projects and we've got tooling on the
right hand side which is going to get a
little bit more practically oriented on
you know bringing products and tools
into these organizations to manage our
projects
okay great thank you appreciate that
um
so the Capstone again we we've referred
to it several times in this presentation
that's because it's it's really a very
valuable tool part of this program
um
you have gone through a bunch of core
courses by the time you reach this point
and you've developed a number of skills
and practiced them in different projects
and case studies and now you have the
opportunity to take a type of problem
that is
faced by companies in the real world
and demonstrate how you solve that
problem how you build your solution to
that challenge how you use skills you've
learned uh to apply to that problem
the way you would as if it was
part of your job in
employment so
this is something that that I have in
your portfolio to show off to potential
employers and to demonstrate your
capabilities project manager so it's a
really strong and important tool for
that
um
that's why you spend the three four
weeks with your instructor as your
advisor
meeting with them weekly
making sure that you're staying out of
any dead ends or traps but getting to
the successful completion and
this program is done under the auspices
of University of Massachusetts Amherst
these are the program advisors who have
set up this curriculum and this program
and oversee its delivery so simply learn
access delivery platform for it we
provide a number of the instructors
recruited from industry
um so these are people like uh Brian who
have extensive experience in Industries
project managers but they operate under
the direction of
Clark Mr Robinson
and
they offer the quality control over the
program
we'll talk about the learner outcomes
because
we have a number of testimonials you'll
see a number more on our website these
are some of the people who have
uh taking project management management
training and
good experiences and we're very proud of
that
um
we're very proud that you can reach out
to us and
resolve any kinds of issues that you may
have along the way and end up with a a
good experience so
um
part of that is the simply learned
career assist service I mentioned that
earlier but I want to go into more
detail about that for U.S Learners I
should say also for India Learners
because usual Learners and Indian
Learners
receive the the suite of Simply learned
career assist Services through different
agencies in the US we work with Talent
Inc in India we work with IIM jobs
both cases we offer you of course access
to Simply learn webinars and computer
events
our ongoing weekly series of
events with industry Leaders with
instructors with many classes and
different topics
with reviews of Industry outlooks and
career outlooks for the coming year and
that type of thing so that's an ongoing
service
the projects that you do within the
program including the Capstone project
but not limited to that one allow you to
create the portfolio that you can show
off to potential employers and then the
job assisted Services directly through
Talent anchor IAM jobs
give you
um
these particular things one is the job
portal in the US it's called resume
rabbit in yeah I believe it's called IAM
jobs which give you access to a certain
set of
job listings
before they go out to the General Public
but even more important than that are
the the resume review and rewrite
service
and the one-on-one job interview
training
resume review and rewrite is important
because today
resumes do not end up on someone's desk
until they've gone through an AI review
process so automated tracking systems
for resumes include AI Bots that
look over the content
and match it up to the job description
you need to understand how to format
your resume and how to word your resume
so that it has the maximum chance
of passing through that filter
but you also need to be able to format
it so that once it does pass through
that filter it goes in front of a pair
of human eyes that it's still attractive
readable presentable puts your
experience in the best light so it's
kind of an art form and one of the great
things about the the career assist
services that we help you with that
working with a resume writer and doing a
couple of drafts of your resume to put
it into its best possible shape for both
purposes of the automated review and the
presentation to people
similarly we do the one-on-one review uh
interview process where we
help you practice
direct interview skills
there are a couple kinds of interviews
of course the people need to to deal
with one is on technical skills but the
other is of course on people skills and
on soft skills and we do interview
practices with you in both areas so that
you're able to talk to the technical
manager about
what your project management skills are
and you're able to talk to
human resources or the higher level
managers about how you work as a team
player and how you can contribute to the
project management process within that
company so
these are very important again we
apologize that they're only available in
the U.S and in India we're working to
expand that to other countries but right
now that's the limitation there mention
the webinars we do these on an ongoing
basis we bring in experts from industry
we bring in for example
Laura from
a major regional Bank in the United
States we have a Ronald Van Loon who's a
noted industry expert in data science
and we have uh carperman who was from
indeed.com and so she gave us some
insights on how to work that job board
uh Myrtle Ann who is a noted consultant
in blockchain these are all the types of
people that we bring in uh in areas of
project management Career Development
technical areas like data science
artificial intelligence
um
software development run courses so you
probably see a webinar that would be a
one hour class on a project management
skill that type of thing so these on an
ongoing basis
and they're free and accessible to
anyone
and the projects here are examples from
this particular
program
these two on the left happen to be
collections from the
offerings for the Capstone project so
you can do a Capstone on agile scrum for
Rapid Innovation
um
this situation would be set up as how
would you do this for a particular
company particular industry planning for
hyper growth yeah that how did you set
up your systems and processes
so that you can address
challenges of what's called a high class
problem of having to grow very rapidly
as the project description says during
the pandemic companies like Zoom for
example
or a company like doordash which is a
meal delivery service
went through
enormous growth extremely rapidly and
but a major strain on the project
management system so
project management skills under those
types of conditions if you can
demonstrate that that's a wonderful
thing to have as well and then along the
way you have the other case studies and
problems
so these all become part of your
portfolio these are all things go to
your future employers as evidence of
your actual experience with project
management skills and tools
um did you have a comment on that
because uh Brian you're you're an
instructor who's
uh dealt with Learners and in their
projects and cap sense and that type of
thing so
um what can you say about this that
might Illustrated it better than I can
yeah well I think you're you're
definitely hitting all the right uh the
notes there
um you know what often this particular
um Capstone in a project provides is an
opportunity for Learners to do two
things one is take what they've learned
and then apply it to something that's
very real world very contemporary
something I think we can look at and say
yeah all these are are things that
organizations are interested in but
possibly as important if not more
important is the opportunity to kind of
partner with someone like myself a a
instructor who has a lot of practical
Real World Experience who can work with
you to kind of craft your Capstone
project in a way that is going to really
resonate with other prospective
employers or your current employer so um
and you know it's often just a great
collaborative exercise it gives you an
opportunity to kind of try out these
techniques get some feedback and then
shape that into something you can take
with you into your current role or to
some other role that you're you're
aspiring to
okay appreciate that
um
so at this point I'm going to ask one
more question
is this your question
is about whether you're knowing what
you've seen so far from Brian and myself
are you interested in enrolling in this
program
will give you about 20 seconds
to give the answer I know it takes uh
sometimes a little time to get the
answer into this widget
leaves us open for another
about 10 seconds now
we'll close the poll
so
and 80 of our audience are interested in
taking this program which is great
um and we're going to show you right now
about how
did I apply that show that here we go
and
um
I'm going to share with you how we
accomplish that
so you have enrollment steps that are
very straightforward
you submit an application start the
process by emailing us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
um I will put that actually into the
chat box right now so that you have that
at your fingertips
and
they will contact you with
the um
application information that you need to
provide
certainly you need to document that you
have your bachelor's degree that's a
prerequisite they'll also ask you to
submit proof of your work experience so
that you demonstrate that you meet the
five-year
requirement
they may assess some of your
aptitude for project management skills
that would be fairly simple assessment
online test and then you if you qualify
if you meet the requirements for the
program they will send you your it's an
offer by email
and
the next cohort of classes actually
starts with a orientation this Thursday
um and the classes themselves start a
couple weekends later on the 17th
so if you want to get started right away
you can do that immediately
um the program fees
uh in India or one lock twelve thousand
four hundred fifty five
which can be financed at
the here on the slide that that's
malformed it's
format the financing can be as low as
300
3733 rupees a month
outside of India the cost of the program
is 2 499 U.S
um and
I think there is a financing option but
you have to
ask the
learning Consultants at ask us something
to learn.net about that
um they can answer any further questions
you've got about
getting into the program the enrollment
process
so that is how you submit your request
for enrollment
that's the pricing of the program and
I'm going to right now stop sharing so
that we can start taking
some of your questions and the answers
and I've logged some of those
up to a certain point
we were talking
it's the
movani asked a quick question for you
Brian uh can you go over the difference
between agile agile scrum and Six Sigma
how they relate to each other
yeah great great question so uh agile is
a um a newer form of project management
delivery or even product delivery which
really centers around people it's all
about how do we get people interacting
collaborating let's focus on lighter
weight techniques that gives us just
enough information that we can build
something get feedback and incrementally
improve it so agile has become very
popular in Industry right now because it
it helps organizations respond to change
so it's a good mechanism for
organizations to kind of try ideas out
get some feedback make adjustments and
you see this particularly in the
technology and software domains now it's
still helpful to have the more
traditional project management practices
that emphasize some planning and making
sure we have a good understanding of
what we're trying to achieve and then
building out a schedule that has a
budget so we don't inside of that but
agile is a really nice complement to
that because it brings the people
together and gets them working in a very
consistent predictable fashion and then
lean Six Sigma is really an opportunity
for us to understand the way we're doing
work and finding ways in which we can be
more efficient more effective so we're
not waiting for things or re-entering
information and doing all the things
that tend to delay us or kind of cause a
lot of rework so um so all that blends
together in this whole program because
as project managers we've kind of see
these as tools tools in a toolkit that
we're going to reach into and use for
different settings and situations
excellent thank you for that
um
just talk uh so the senator says I'm not
technical I don't have a coding
background uh how will project
management help me to grow in a career
yeah yeah great what advice do you have
for somebody who comes out of a
non-technical background and would want
to apply project management in their
career
well you know I think this brings it
back to uh to what you started the the
whole session with right which is hey
project management is used everywhere
um so you really don't need a technical
programmatic background uh these are a
set of practices that we can extend into
so many different domains regardless of
Industry regardless of the type of
organization you know we we use these
techniques even when we're doing things
at home like cleaning our garage right
we understand okay what is it I'm trying
to achieve how much time do I have
what's the most important thing I need
to get done what's my schedule
availability so I I think the fact that
you don't have a programming background
is absolutely fine in fact generally
speaking this is a good path for people
that don't have that kind of technical
orientation or Focus this is a great way
if you've got more people skills
management skills if you are a natural
organizer these are all the types of
skills that you'll really be able to
Showcase as a project manager
okay
appreciate that and as I
like you said Brian I mentioned up front
that project management is a universal
skill so
wherever you're going in your career
it's something that will will help you
uh achieve
um Ambrose asked what what are the
typical times for classes on weekends on
Saturdays and Sundays
can you comment on that or does it vary
a lot I think it really varies you know
um I think for a lot of people the
weekend courses are uh very you know fit
well into your your typical work uh and
home life schedule but you know for for
others you know they might find the
evenings are a good place to kind of
settle in and and focus on some course
interior so the nice thing about the
programming is you've got all those
options available to you so whatever is
going to fit best for you you can find
the the courses you've got the
self-paced learning you've got the
community to engage with so lots of
different ways in which you can access
this this learning experience
okay
um
is there a particular programming
language that people learn as part of
this program
well we're not really going to put as
much emphasis on programming languages
in this type of course but you will get
exposures to some specific tools we saw
Microsoft Project we saw jira we saw a
minitab so those tools are going to be
really important for project managers
but we really won't be doing a lot of
programming per se
yeah
um
okay who asked the project PMP
certification confers eligibility
um so you still need to have the five
years of work experience on the
bachelor's degree in order to become
eligible for the program
um
Chandra made an interesting comment uh
that
he had originally applied to UMass
Amherst for a civil engineering master's
degree didn't get in but he did his
master's uh digital business in New
Zealand with a top of class score so he
just wanted to point out a little humble
Brandon
University but uh
Chandra if this is a program that you
want to engage in the
requirements to enter are very different
so don't don't feel like you're in any
kind of disadvantage and in fact the
fact that you distinguish yourself with
your uh master's program in New Zealand
definitely a plus Factor so
um but another question came in about
whether this is a master's degree
program it is not
a master's degree program it is a
postgraduate certification program so it
gives you skills training but it is not
part of the academic Masters program at
University of Massachusetts or part of
the MBA program as I mentioned however
if you complete this program
you can get a head start on a MBA from
Eisenberg School of Management at UMass
Amherst in their online program
because it will give you nine credits
that you can apply to that
or you can use it towards your MBA
degrees though it does give you a head
start in that respect
um
is it required to have a PMP
certification trying to prior to
starting this program
so Brian is that a uh no or not
definitely definitely not required in
fact uh this is going to prepare you to
get your PMP certification
um and by the way for those maybe not
really familiar with that certification
it is a global industry standard for
project management project managers and
it's it's a demanding exam I take it
from a person that's not just completed
the exam but also I write many of the
exam certification questions for the PMI
so um so this is a great way to get
ready for that demanding exam prepare
for that and get that certification
which will really act as a as a
demonstration of your your expertise and
knowledge in this space
uh thank you so dark uh says it's about
to start our program on digital
transformation uh beginning this weekend
in fact and
um he asked if you would recommend to
get PMP certification along with that or
is that covered in the digital
transformation course before you answer
that I'm going to say that we're looking
at
the US Amherst um
project management program today so we
may not be able to answer off the top of
our head about the other program the
administration program but in general in
digital transformation that's one of the
options one of the uh electives in this
program
um so do you how do you see digital
transformation in project management
skills uh working hand in hand brand
yeah good great question and and really
what um when we think of digital
transformation this is how organizations
are making this shift to more of a
digital way in which they are satisfying
customers and creating products and
supporting what they've sold uh and
really shifting as much as they can into
more automated software-driven practices
away from more manual oriented processes
so if you think of it as this is a place
organization is trying to get to you
know they know that they want to become
more digital what they need help with is
how they do that and this is where a
project manager steps in Project
managers are going to understand okay
this is where you're trying to get to
this is how much money you have to spend
this is how much time you want to
allocate let's figure out the people we
need the risk we might be exposed to how
we're going to manage or and track our
progress so project managers are really
instrumental in helping organizations
transform into a digital organization
okay
um
we have several questions about the PMP
certification exam the
once somebody has completed that first
module of this program on PMP
um are they eligible then to go straight
into taking the test and
um
what what is the process there
right right yeah once you've taken the
PMP course then you're going to be very
familiar with the whole project
management
body of knowledge and the PMI framework
so you are ready to take that exam now
remember when we were kind of looking at
the LMS we saw some of those practice
assessments those are really helpful
because this is a pretty tough exam so
you want to do some practice and what
simply learned is has been doing this
for many many years they know the types
of questions are going to be asked and
they know what Learners need so so
definitely take advantage of that take
your certification exam as soon as you
realistically can after completing the
course get that under your belt and keep
marching through the rest of the content
and there's a question about whether the
exam uh DMP exam price is part of the
course oh there's a voucher for the exam
I would ask folks that ask us at simply
learned not that question I don't have
the answer off the top of my head I
don't want to tell you that it is if it
isn't so please do ask that uh from our
learning Consultants
um
how does this program recognize in India
so the project management
certifications and skills are
recognized worldwide so things that
you'll learn in this course and
especially things aligned with the PMI
are certifications that will be
recognized
Wherever You Are
um
the that's one of the things about
simply learn is it's
founder started the company uh helping
people study for project management
certification in India we're based in
Bangalore so
the
the Indian
Learners definitely get value out of the
program
let's see
is there a value
corporate world and having this training
without the PMP certification
would you
say that
would you say that those two things
should go in hand in hand or or
are the independent yeah sorry we were
just asking should I get a PMP in
addition to this
yeah I mean I think the question here is
from Shannon who says you know is there
a value in the corporate world not
getting PMP certification from PMI
oh yeah yeah for sure I mean at the end
of the PMI is still you know absolutely
the the global industry standard for
project management so having that
certification uh it's really
demonstrating that you understand and
have been you know tested against quite
a rigorous exam on these Concepts and
these ideas and these practices uh so so
many organizations actually are going to
if you're hiring a project manager are
going to look for a PMI certification as
a way to validate that this is the right
person for the role yeah it's it's a
valuable thing to have in one of the
it's as Brian described one of the
effects of this program is it qualifies
you to take that test so it's basically
the type of thing that that um you know
you're getting the value
um
may as well take that extra step and get
the certification
um we have a question from swapnil I'm
going to ask swapnil to contact our
learning Consultants that ask us it's
important.net but his question is I'm
already setting with a PMP program from
Simply learn uh is it possible to
upgrade to this postgraduate program
um so I would definitely ask the folks
at um
and that's because it's simple learn.net
or learning Consultants can tell you
whether or not you can in fact transfer
that and apply the the fees from the
program you're into this one but I can't
answer that question off the top of my
head
um a deal asked an interesting question
I showed four four projects on us at one
of the slides and yes will we do all
four of these projects as part of the
program how many projects does this
program include Brandon yeah roughly
roughly speaking Yeah Yeah it's a great
question I think his question might have
been oriented around the uh before
Capstone projects so you'll get a chance
to pick one of those because these are
pretty intensive you won't be able to do
all four
um we really want to focus on one but
throughout all the courses you are going
to get lots of opportunities to
participate in case studies uh you saw
the one on agile on Smart weather it's a
new weather app you get to kind of
develop a the agile structure around and
kind of to talk about how you're going
to manage that from an agile perspective
so each one of the courses give you a
chance to kind of practically apply
these skills with some kind of case
study experience
and uh we had a question from
I know we're running over time so I'm
going to take this as our last question
Maria
is a project manager in a digital agency
so
how is this program valuable for Arya
and are there any suggestions you might
make about the tools that are most
appropriate to her situation
yeah I think that's uh again a great
question so if you're working in sort of
that you know digital marketing ad space
um all these skills are gonna you know
be very very relevant to that it's going
to help you with organizing oftentimes
in that space you have multiple projects
here you're managing so having a good
understanding of how you're organizing
those how what their schedules budgets
look like but it also gives you a path
for growth and it positions you to kind
of expand into larger programs and and
support bigger initiatives
um so it's it's a it's a great way not
only to learn skills you can apply in
your current environment but also
position you for moving into bigger and
better opportunities
great
um and so at this point I'm going to
apologize to everybody's questions
a lot of great questions out there
um so I'm going to go ahead and ask the
last question of our own from this
audience
this question is
if you are interested
seen all the information about the
program now and
how soon would you like to get started
so
are you interested in joining that
cohort
getting into that orientation session
later this week starting classes in
about a week and a half are you looking
at do that maybe in the one after that
in a month or two after that
um or are you looking further out so
again we always say that if this is
something that is going to improve your
life in your career
but sooner than later is probably a good
idea but uh it's always based on your
personal situation
here's the poll results
a number of you are interested in
getting started right away in that next
cohort in
cluding the people who are looking at
the one after that or within a couple of
months a total of 40 of the audience so
that's great and we would like to invite
you to send us
um
your initial request and ask us at
7learn.net but I'd like to say to the
the rest of you you're interested in
starting this program further down the
road please do contact us at ask us at
simplelearn.net and
get into the process not to apply it
necessarily right away but to um
stay in contact with us and get your
additional questions answered so that
you can make a
quick decision when it comes time and
I'm going to put into the chat window
again
so you can find it more easily
I'm going to put into the chat window
again both the uh
email address sorry
and
the link to the program
home page on our website
so you can go there and download the
syllabus for the program
get a little more detail
but I do encourage everyone to contact
us and ask us at simplylearn.net ask the
Learning Management learning Consultants
there about
the process in about the program and
with that I'm going to thank Brian for
being so generous with this time I
apologize for the technical difficulties
on my end and
um
again
really great having you here again today
Brian yeah great session appreciate the
invite and thanks everyone for joining
us today looking forward to to
connecting with you all when you enroll
the program
okay and to everyone who joined us uh
this evening this morning wherever you
are in the world uh we do thank you for
being here we appreciate your interest
in the program and we hope we can
welcome you into the Learning Community
with UMass Amherst and simplylearn
with that
so we've included our webinar for today
so thanks again and we hope to hear from
you soon
all right thanks everyone have a great
day everyone